غالبًا ما يكون آخر شيء نفكر فيه بشأن
الاعتناء بأنفسنا هو التركيز على صحتنا
العقلية وهو جزء مهم من
الصحة العامة. تقول طبيبتنا النفسية جنيفر
زومارجا من شركة El Camino Health أن
هناك أنواعًا عديدة من الرعاية الذاتية ولكنها تطلب من
مرضاها التركيز  على ثلاثة منها،
أولًا جسديًا يعني ممارسة
التمارين الرياضية مع قدر كافٍ من النوم
بالإضافة إلى تناول الطعام الصحيح، تظهر الأبحاث
أن الحصول على وجبات منتظمة
ومتوازنة وجيدة وحتى بعض
الأطعمة الممتعة التي تعرفها، تستمتع بتلك الأطعمة
المهمة جدًا حقًا بالإضافة إلى
الترطيب التالي.  هو الجانب العاطفي
من الرعاية الذاتية الذي يتمثل في
التأمل أو القيام بتقنيات التنفس
أو كتابة اليوميات، كما تقول إنها تتعلق أيضًا
بممارسة الإيجابية. أريد دائمًا
التحدث عن ممارسة الامتنان حقًا
وتذكير أنفسنا بالأشياء
التي نشعر بالامتنان لها والتي لدينا في
حياتنا أخيرًا هذا الجانب الاجتماعي من
الصحة العقلية عندما أغلق العالم
أثناء الوباء، أصبح الكثير من الناس معزولين.
تقول زومارجا إنه من المهم أن تكون لديك
علاقات مع الآخرين،
وتتواصل حقًا مع أفراد العائلة والأصدقاء
وتحاول حقًا بناء تلك الصداقات
والحصول على الدعم من الآخرين  سيكون الأمر
مهمًا للغاية بالنسبة لنا
ولصحتنا العقلية والرعاية الذاتية للصحة،
أنا آندي جايثر